We now know how to name
aldehydes and ketones, and
what I want to do in this video
is show a mechanism for
actually creating one.
In particular, we're going
to create a ketone.
So let's say we've got ourselves
some benzene, and in
the first step of this reaction,
the benzene is just
going to sit and watch.
We've got some benzene
and we've got
some of acetyl chloride.
So it looks almost like an
aldehyde or a ketone, but
instead of having a carbon chain
or a hydrogen, we're
going to have a chlorine
atom right over there.
So this is acetyl chloride,
sometimes called acyl chloride.
This is acetyl chloride, and
we're going to have an
aluminum chloride catalyst. And
a catalyst means that it
participates in the reaction,
but it enters the reaction and
it exits the reaction as
the same molecule.
So it just catalyzes it.
It doesn't disappear.
It just changes halfway,
but then goes back
to what it was before.
So we have some aluminum
chloride and it's bonded to
one, two, three chlorines.
Now, the first step of this
reaction is to turn this
acetyl chloride into a good
electrophile, turn it into
something that's really good at
nabbing electrons, so good
that it can break the
aromaticity of the benzene
ring and essentially add itself
to the benzene ring.
This is actually the same
mechanism we saw with
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
I always have trouble
remembering the name, but I
always imagine it's
electrophilic substitution.
Either way, but it's a very
similar mechanism.
And actually, what we're going
to show in this video is
called Friedel-Crafts acylation,
because this right
here is called an acyl group and
we're essentially going to
acylate the benzene ring.
We're going to add this
group right here
to the benzene ring.
So enough of what's
going to happen.
Let's actually see it happen.
So the first thing to realize,
this aluminum chloride, the
aluminum in it is electron
deficient.
And at first, if you just look
at the Periodic Table, you
have these chlorines over here,
pretty electronegative.
Aluminum is in the same row, but
chlorine's way more to the
right, so it's more
electronegative, so the
chlorines are going to hog the
electrons in this molecule.
The chlorines are going to hog
electrons, so the aluminum is
going to have a partial
positive charge.
Chlorines will have slightly
partial negative charge.
On top of that, you see aluminum
is a Group 3 element,
one, two, three, so it has
three valence electrons.
You see that right here, one,
two, three, nowhere close to
the magic number of eight.
Even when it covalently bonds
with these chlorines, it can
only pretend like it
has six electrons.
It can kind of pretend like it
has these chlorine electrons
over here, but that only
gets it to six.
So it would really like to have
more electrons to get
closer to that magic
eight number.
So what you can imagine is a
situation where this chlorine
on the acetyl chloride, it's
already hogging this green
electron from this carbon.
It was already doing that.
It's more electronegative, so
this thing over here will
actually be given
to the aluminum.
And so it will then have a
bond with the chloride.
So if that happened, what does
our reaction look like?
everything look like?
Our aluminum, our aluminum
chloride, or what was formerly
aluminum chloride, now just
gained an electron, and with
it, it is now bonded to
another chlorine.
So it is now bonded to another
chlorine, and since it gains
an electron-- let me
make it very clear.
This is an L.
My penmanship is
deteriorating.
That's an L.
And since this aluminum gained
an electron, it now has a
negative charge.
And normally, a negatively
charged thing isn't that
stable, but these guys are
electronegative, so they might
hog a lot of that
negative charge.
And on top of it, aluminum
can now pretend like
it has eight electrons.
It has one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
When you covalently bond to
someone, you can kind of
pretend like you have their
electrons as well.
So now you have this anion
that was formed from the
aluminum chloride, and now
the acetyl chloride
will look like this.
Scroll down a little bit.
Let me make it clear.
We're in the next step
of the reaction.
What was formerly the acetyl
chloride has now lost the
chloride, so it's now really
just an acyl group.
So you have the carbonyl bonded
to a CH3, a methyl,
just like that.
This guy lost his electrons,
so now he
has a positive charge.
And this is actually
not that stable.
you're going to see it's
actually highly reactive.
It's a very good electrophile.
It wants to steal other
people's electrons.
But it can exist for a short
amount of time, especially
because it is resonant
stabilized.
You say, how is it resonant
stabilized?
Well, this oxygen over here has
two electron pairs that I
didn't draw before.
And let me draw the second
one in a different color.
It has two electron
pairs like that.
So you can imagine
the situation.
This carbon is already-- he has
a positive charge, and his
oxygen is more electronegative.
It's already hogging
his electrons.
Maybe he wants to give
back a little bit.
Say, hey, this is positive.
All of the electrons are
hanging out here.
They'd be attracted to the
positive, and you could
imagine one of these
electrons being
given back to the carbon.
And if that happened then we
have another resonance form
that looks like this.
So this was our original
molecule.
That's our original, or
what it looked like.
We still have this double bond
right over there or that pair
of electrons.
Now, this pair of electrons
now forms another bond.
This electron here is now
on the oxygen end.
This electron over here is now
on the carbon end, and now
they have a triple bond.
And what happened?
This positive carbon gained an
electron, so it's now neutral.
And the neutral oxygen
lost an electron,
so it is now positive.
And you could imagine, this
is not a very stable-- you
wouldn't see this just floating
around by itself, but
it does stabilize this
entire configuration.
It stabilizes this molecule.
So you can show that these
are alternate resonantly
stabilized structures
right there.
But as I said, these aren't
super stable.
This guy really, really,
really wants to react.
And now this is where benzene
comes into the mix.
And actually, let me draw a
little dividing line here,
just so we know that
this was a separate
stage of our reaction.
So that was the first stage.
Then we go over here and now
benzene comes into the mix.
The benzene was floating
around.
So we have our benzene floating
around, just like that.
And then I'm going to draw
one of the hydrogens
on one of the carbons.
All of these carbons have
hydrogens on them.
I just won't draw them all.
It just make things
complicated.
But this guy we said is a really
good electrophile, and
you have to be a really good
electrophile to attract
electrons from a benzene ring,
to break it's aromaticity.
But if it bumps into this guy in
just the right way, at just
the right angle, you could
imagine that this electron on
this carbon right here gets
swiped by the acyl group.
So then what do we have?
So now I will go back
in this direction.
So you have what was
a benzene ring.
We can draw the double
bonds here and here.
And we, of course, have
this hydrogen.
But now this bond, which was
a double bond there, is now
bonded to the acyl group.
So it has that blue electron
that the acyl group nabbed.
And let me draw the
acyl group.
And I'll flip it over so that
we have the methyl on the
right-hand side.
So it's carbonyl bonded
to a CH3.
It was positive.
It now gained an electron.
It is now neutral.
This carbon over here lost
an electron, so it is now
positive, so it is now
positively charged.
Now, we mentioned the aluminum
chloride is a catalyst, so it
won't just sit around
there as the anion.
It has to go back to being
aluminum chloride, so let's
bring the aluminum chloride
back into the scene.
So we have our aluminum
chloride.
Let me copy and paste it.
So we have our aluminum chloride
here, and so you can
imagine that the benzene ring
wants to go back to being
aromatic, so this electron right
here on the hydrogen
might really want to go back
to this carbon right over
here, this carbocation.
At the same time, if this anion
now passes the hydrogen
at just the right angle at the
right time while this guy's
attracted to this carbon, this
chlorine can give this green
electron to the hydrogen
nucleus, which is
really just a proton.
And then the hydrogen's electron
can be taken up by
what was this carbocation.
And then what do we have?
Then we have a situation where
our benzene ring is reformed.
We have the aromaticity again.
We have that double bond, that
double bond, and now we have
this double bond again, although
now it's using the
electron from the hydrogen.
And now we've substituted this
hydrogen with essentially this
acyl group right over here.
So we have a carbon double
bonded to an oxygen bonded to
a methyl group.
And now the aluminum, or this
anion, lost its electron, so
it goes back to just being
straight-up aluminum chloride.
It goes back to just being
straight-up neutral,
electron-deficient aluminum
chloride.
And we're done.
We've just acylized this benzene
ring, and that's why
this mechanism is called
Friedel-Crafts acylation.
And Friedel is actually a former
president of MIT, and I
did some reading on this.
Apparently, he did not have a
PhD, but because he discovered
Friedel-Crafts acylation and
this Friedel-Crafts alkylation
as well, they said, hey, you
know, this guy's a smart dude.
Let's make him the
president of MIT.
But I just wanted to show you
that this is a reaction for
creating a ketone.
So this ketone that we've
created is acetophenone, which
we've seen before, which we've
learned is a common name for
this molecule that we learned
in the first ketone video.
And I'll write it in purple.
Acetophenone.
And we're done!